dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on AFA here today we
are going to talk a bit about the glory
and the woes of cloth simulation
programs in these simulations we have
several 3d models that are built from up
to several hundreds of thousands of
triangles and as they move in time the
interesting part of the simulation is
whenever collisions happen however
evaluating how these meshes collide is
quite difficult and time consuming
basically we have to tell an algorithm
that we have a piece of cloth with a
hundred thousand connected triangles
here and another one there and now have
a look and tell me which collides with
which and how they Bend and change in
response to these forces and don't
forget about friction and repulsive
forces also please be accurate because
every small error adds up over time and
do it several times a second so we can
have a look at the results interactively
well this is a quite challenging problem
and it takes quite long to compute so
much so that's 70 to 80 percent of the
total time taken to perform the
simulation is spent with collision
handling so how can we make it not take
forever well one way would be to try to
make sure that we can run this collision
handling step on the graphics card this
is exactly what this work does and in
order to do this we have to make sure
that all of these evaluations can be
performed in parallel of course this is
easier said than done another difficulty
is choosing the appropriate time steps
these simulations are run in a way that
we check and resolve all of the
collisions and then we can advance the
simulation forward by a tiny amount this
amount is called a time step and
choosing the appropriate time step has
always been a challenge you see if we
set it to too large we will be done
faster and compute less however we will
almost certainly miss some collisions
because we skipped over them the
simulation may end up in a state that is
so incorrect that it is impossible to
recover from and we have to throw the
tire thing out if we set it to too low
we get a more robust simulation however
it will take many hours two days to
compute to remedy this this technique is
built in a way such that we can use
larger time steps that's excellent news
also the collision computation part is
now up to nine times faster and if we
look at the cloth simulation as a whole
that can be made over three times faster
as you see here this is especially nice
because we can test how these garments
react to our manipulations at eight to
ten frames per second if you have a
closer look at the paper you will find
another key observation which states
that most of the time only a small sub
region of the simulated cloth undergoes
deformation due to response forces and
this knowledge can be kept track of
which contributed to cutting down the
simulation time significantly thanks for
watching and for your generous support
now see you next time